hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here so a
pretty general theory I've had going for
a while now is every product category
that's well established enough has a
go-to like an easy to recommend checks
all the boxes safe bet straight shot
right down the middle like if you want a
mouse there's the Logitech MX series
that's been around if you want a
microphone the Shure sm7b is like the
standard for phones it's like the iPhone
now this doesn't mean that this is the
one for everyone in fact it usually
isn't for everyone you use that as a
sort of a starting point and then when
you find the the values you have and the
things you like then you Veer off into
the Alternatives that you might pay more
for but there's always that starting go
to and so for wireless earbuds that
aren't airpods
the go-to is the Samsung Galaxy buds
Plus for sure 100 and they should be now
that doesn't mean they're perfect that
doesn't mean they're for everyone but
they check all of the fundamental boxes
that make them incredibly easy to
recommend and enjoy they're pretty great
so what's so great about these 150
dollar wireless earbuds well when you
look at what you want from these they
got to be small check they got to be
lightweight check they got to fit in
your ears and that's a check for me they
do fit well in my ear comfortably thanks
to the rubber tips unlike air pods and
they actually create a sort of a passive
seal now they're not active noise
canceling but you know at this price you
don't really see that that much but the
seal is actually enough that I don't
miss it that much and I realize
everyone's ears are different so you
know different people will have slightly
different fits but I was really
impressed with the fit of these earbuds
and how snug they are in my ear now I'd
personally still rather have an active
noise cancellation version of these
that's for my values and what I like
like so if they made that like a pro
version I'd be super cool with that but
even just putting these in my ear I feel
like I'm talking louder because they
create that seal and dim down the
environment and by the time you start
playing music
you don't really hear much else so for
flying and mass transit and construction
and Loud stuff maybe this isn't the way
to go but generally for everyday use
pretty good so they're comfortable then
they have a legitimate Best in Class 11
hour battery life for music listening
which is mostly what I do with earbuds
and that's great and fast charging but
honestly being able to go a full week of
casual listening and not having any
battery anxiety till like the last day
of the week is awesome and then speaking
of charging the case these sit in are
also pretty textbook you can't forget
about the case it's small and slim it's
just as pocketable and lightweight as
airpods and it has USB type c for
charging and it's also capable of
wireless charging if you want to put it
on the back of your phone or on any
wireless charger it'll do that too and
it even has a nice hinge weight and
magnets for the lid to open and close
with a satisfying click
it's maybe not quite as satisfying as
pixel buds but that's a pretty good
click the buds are built well they have
this sort of a rubber fin around the
outside that helps them seat in your ear
instead of like one little piece poking
out that can get kind of painful and I
found that this was enough to stay in my
ears really well not quite as locked in
as say the jaybirds with the full-on
wingtips on those things but locked in
enough that I felt comfortable working
out in them it had no problems they stay
in my ears and speaking of working out
these are ipx2 rated so some sweat is
fine now I still I would say they
shouldn't be dedicated workout
headphones like maybe Power Beats or
anything ipx7 certified but if you wear
them every day and you like happen to
step out and sweat while wearing them or
do a quick workout they are fine and
then the touch controls are also really
simple both earbuds have that pretty
large touchpad surface and that's where
you play pause that's where you fast
forward accept calls long press first
assistant all that stuff I've been using
them with my OnePlus 8 Pro so they call
Google Assistant not Bixby but they work
fine with any Android phone or iPhone
for that matter but they do work a
little bit better with a Samsung phone
because then you can get the Galaxy buds
app and that gives you a little more
control over customizing media controls
and Ambient sound pass-through but
generally even without that app they've
been Rock Solid no connection issues
even walking across the studio leaving
my phone over here having them in my
backpack no problem and then the sound
from these guys was really quite good I
was very impressed and happy with the
sound from these they have what I would
call a very full sound they have a big
rich full bass crisp clean mids and
highs no background hisss these are
tuned by AKG and they're proud to put
their name on it and I can see why the
only complaint I could see coming from a
different pair of earbuds or headphones
is these may actually feel a bit bass
heavy if you're not used to all this but
they can turn that down in the EQ quite
easily but I'll tell you right now I
won't be doing that I listen to a lot of
music and the way they sound out the box
is great it's already great for music I
think I'd go so far as to say these are
the best sounding non-noise canceling
wireless earbuds I've tried this is the
truth right now honestly it makes me
kind of wish I brought them out on the
channel sooner I don't really have
anything bad to say about these but I'm
gonna nitpick because that's what you do
and that's how you get products to be
better the next time around I'm sure
Samsung was working on a next version of
these so what I'll say is these don't
really look that great to me I feel like
they could do with a little bit better
of a design I mean I guess almost none
really look that great but to me pixel
buds do look really good and I love the
colors I wish airpods did colors too
like this but I don't know for some
reason it looks like it feels like cheap
plastic to me I think maybe a matte
finish that the more premium ones got
going on looks better and I think that
could have saved these a bit too but
look Galaxy buds Plus
it's the go-to just remember the name
you know they the battery life I think
is their best feature and that's a nice
relaxing comfortable feature to have be
really good but the sound is really good
the fit in my ears is really good the
microphones are pretty good and then the
case is great
just checks all the boxes so it's like
now that you know about these you might
decide oh okay what I know I like I want
to spend more because I want noise
cancellation and then you can go get
active noise cancellation you spend a
bit more and there's plenty of options
for those like the Sony is an airpods
Pro or you might go you know what I like
these but I also want them to be more
workout focused headphones then you go
for something with better waterproofing
or more of the wingtip fit in the ear
stuff like the Jay birds or Powerbeats
so there's other headphones that do
plenty of things better than these but
if there's anyone out there wondering
what's the de facto set of non-air PODS
wireless earbuds
there you go Samsung Galaxy buds plus
now you know so there you have it thanks
for watching catch you guys in the next
one
peace